no one's gonna go out to eat this is
what we're really gonna what it's coming
down to when you when we go through all
the rules that I mean did no one I love
going out to eat it's no one loves it
that much that you're gonna sit there
and then people are gonna come out and
be keeper outfits and then hand you a
butter and then there's gonna be a ball
of hand sanitizer and there's not gonna
be any tablecloth so they're gonna be
wiping down the table hey it's gonna be
a car wash who the hell wants to eat in
a [ __ ] car wash where everything what
are you smiling about I'm reading the
rules the rules are in saya read some of
the rules these are some of the rules
for this Italian restaurant in Long
Island - just to just get back to
serving any kind of food inside all
right
reopening guidelines all employees will
wear gloves and mask during service
until recommended by the CDC or in New
York State fun so let's just picture
that you're at a table you're at a table
in the restaurant in Long Island by the
way half of these people aren't
following the rules they're gonna take
the match they'll be like you know this
is [ __ ]
the whole thing is fake but Obama what
you know Obama created this to make a
[ __ ] us wear masks yeah so I gotta
[ __ ] wear this [ __ ] hand sanitizer
will be readily available to guests hand
sanitizer will be readily available and
I'm sure Long Island they'll do it in a
very classy way I'm sure there's gonna
be very classy way to get hand sanitizer
to the guests like thousands of it that
are you know lit on fire there's gonna
be like hand sanitizer ice luge's
in steak houses in Long Island people
just stick in their dirty myths in a
[ __ ] big bowl of hand sanitizer I'm
sure that I'm sure that's smart masks
and gloves will be provided by the
restaurant please alert management if
there is none great so not only are the
waitstaff in masks and gloves you will
get masks and gloves from the management
so that
you can put it on so you can have gloves
and a mask on while you're eating so
that you just take the mask down and eat
and then put the mask back up I guess I
guess I guess I guess I don't know I
don't know how well thought thought-out
this is all tables are disinfected
before and after seedings in service
hours good so they cut so they disinfect
it right in front of you like a wool
like you know like you like sitting at
Wendy's where they come up with the
spray bottle and then they wipe it down
there's nothing better than paying $75
for a steak and getting the table
sprayed down in front of you by a guy in
a mask kitchen will be sanitized I mean
that makes sense well it won't be but
that's anything out of sight well
nothing's happening especially in Long
Island we're not doing any of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the kitchen keep the food coming
keep it hot keep it coming all surfaces
are wipes down disinfected routinely
following cleaning schedule great so
just every surface you see he's gonna
get get a dirty rag going across it
multiple times a night there's nothing
better than going out for a romantic
meal and just watching people clean God
nothing better than the smell of hand
sanitizer and disinfected which were all
[ __ ] desensitized to now by the way
just a smell Avenger oh honey how are
you don't you enjoy that what's that
aroma
oh it's ammonia do you like it it's the
chemical that's gonna kill us and in
several years worse than the coronavirus
well it's this is nine pages long it's
not pet keep going for a little bit I
just want to know as few more of the
things all sanitation is scheduled and
recorded okay
health guest health guests will be asked
for contact info for notification this
is what it gets good keep going with
this this is some of my favorite read
this again guests will be asked for
contact info for notifications of
contagion and pledge that they have not
felt any symptoms of kovin 19 a pledge
and we all know in Long Island
it's a truthful group
of people so they will and they're also
gonna be asked about their family
history before they get in the
restaurant by the way that's gonna cheer
everybody up so I hate Vinny we hate to
do this but you know anybody to try to
Co yeah my mother [ __ ] died in a
[ __ ] nursing home I'm trying to
[ __ ] forget that Cuomo let it [ __ ]
burn in attics you're lit in a fire let
them [ __ ] burn this [ __ ] let
it burn it gives himself a raise I was
trying to forget about that but coming
out here to LA abbondanza and try to
have [ __ ] lasagna and now I gotta
talk about it okay this one I don't
understand
Matilda's law will be enforced as long
as it remains in effect
okay Matilda's law a lot of people don't
know what Matilda's law is on Long
Island Matilda's law is if if a woman is
enough of a [ __ ] she doesn't have to
follow any of these rules some Matilda's
law has named after a woman named
Matilda uh Fabrice ecoan and she was in
Italian Jew and she was the most
annoying person it's ever lived and no
matter what the law is she's such a [ __ ]
and she's so loud that they just let her
she's like I'm not putting on no [ __ ]
masks
I don't give a [ __ ] I don't know so
that's the Matilda's law they don't I
don't know I'm it told his lawyers okay
so this one I don't know if this holds
up customers over 70 are not allowed to
dine within our walls or nice I love
that customers over 70 which is everyone
on Long Island the youngest person in
Long Island is in their mid-60s everyone
over 70 is not allowed to dine within
our walls how nice is that
seven year-olds can't go to dinner
anymore Wow
seventies not that old either
no it's not seventy years old you can't
go to dinner now within our walls you
can eat in the parking lot you can eat
in the lot employees will take and
record contactless temperature checks as
well as take health pledge daily the
health pledge
I'm sure no one will lie about that and
by the way what if you have a symptom of
Kovan you don't have Colvin right
doesn't this sound inse-- like it it
seems like it's a lot and by the way if
it this is that transmissible does any
is this [ __ ] even help
well max c'mon parties are for maximum
parties of four I like that I do like
that someone's got to go try to ensure
guests stay separate while waiting to be
seated correct so if one tip party for
comes in and another party for comes in
and they might want to talk to each
other because they live in the same
neighborhood or know each other they
can't do that somebody's gonna have to
come up to them and go Liz will you two
shut the [ __ ] up and you here's what's
hilarious about this do you know how in
artfully this is gonna be done on Long
Island do you have any idea how you know
you're not supposed to [ __ ] talk cut
the [ __ ] talk it out just shut the
[ __ ] up for five minutes we're getting a
table tonic god we don't want to get
shut down by the government I mean do
you know how poorly this will all be
executed longer I don't they don't make
it a day with all of these regulations
there's no way this even happens in Long
Island there's no way there's a whole
section about mental health oh use a
whole section about mental health is you
say it is an island where I would say on
Long Island thirty percent of people are
mentally ill mentally unwell thirty
percent of them are mentally unwell the
whole section about mental health we've
all heard it if you can't take the heat
then best out of the kitchen but all too
often in the restaurant industry the
heat burns on longer than your ship this
mandatory pause the service has allowed
us to consider what's already a global
issue and how service mental well-being
yeah mental well-being great